stellen Sie sich vor bei jeder Lüge der
Grünen würde die Nase vom
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
ein Stückchen wachsen Fans von Pinocchio
hätten ihre wahre Freude denn Gründe für
das märchenhafte nasenwachstum gibt es
viele und es werden immer mehr
das ein weiter Betrieb der letzten drei
deutschen Atommeiler beim Erreichen der
Klimaziele helfen würde passt Habeck so
gar nicht in den Plan laut den Grünen
sei angeblich die Mehrzahl der Bürger
für das AKW aus doch da haben Harbeck
und seine Partei wohl vergessen die
Menschen außerhalb ihrer Ministerien zu
befragen angeblich könnten Brennstäbe
für den Weiterbetrieb der AKW nicht
rechtzeitig geliefert werden so Robert
habe inzwischen wäre die Lügen Nase des
Robert Habeck schon so lang dass sie
sogar aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium herausragt
also für jeden sichtbar